[Music]
hey I'm Gabe Hall writer and this is a
hashtag news quickie guys that means
it's gonna be quick this last week was
New York Comic Con and we learned a lot
about one of our favorite upcoming shows
Jessica Jones and fans got a sneak peek
at the supposedly amazing first episode
too bad I missed it it's stuck in this
blue void the void is my wife here's
what we learned number one
Luke Cage might be the wham bam thank
you Superman tight while Luke Cage
Jessica Jones go on to have a great
though unique relationship in the comics
Mike Colter the actor playing Luke Cage
has revealed that his own spin-off show
will lift him out of Hell's Kitchen and
place him in Harlem now that's only like
20 or 30 minutes away so you know
overlaps and overnights
could still happen but having the
characters home base officially be in a
different part of New York at least
tells us that these two won't be moving
in together anytime soon Coulter also
revealed that when we find him on the
show he's on the run from something he's
laying low in Hell's Kitchen and trying
to make ends meet basically just keep it
to himself he's a fugitive on the run
cariann Moss's character is revealed we
previously didn't know who the matrix
actor was playing but now it turns out
that they tricked us with a gender swap
yeah you never see that coming the
gender swap she's a female there's no
female pods left
gender swap she's playing a female
version of jeryn hogarth though it
sounds like she might be going by Jerry
I don't know either way she's a powerful
lawyer that has a complicated
relationship with Jessica Jones
they both grate on each other's nerves
they're not they're not best friends
what's interesting about her inclusion
is that in the comics Jaron is not only
a man but much much more connected to
the iron fist and I'll come back to that
in my burning questions Netflix is
growing for it though no boobies fimo
asked in his video if we thought Netflix
and Marvel would go all the way with the
adult content into the Jessica Jones
storyline you can check that video out
here if you want to know more about that
stuff but don't let your parents catch
you it's very r-rated some of it he
drops that bombs
I want shape but people at New York
Comic Con got to see an episode or two
from what it sounds like they're going
all the way with this stuff except for
nudity and the F star star K word but
again all the stuff they'll have talked
about in that video all that explicit
stuff seems to be in there and seems
like the purple man might do some crazy
stuff he didn't even do in the comics
finally we may be getting a nuke now in
the comics daredevil villain Frank
Simpson becomes nuke an American flag
tattooed adrenaline-fueled supervillain
that goes on killing rampages that's
great he's another one of those messed
up results of the Super Soldier Serum
seriously kids don't do the Super
Soldier Serum like you got to get off
that stuff and in the show we're getting
a character named Will Simpson who it
looks like is a reimagined version of
nuke okay so here are the burning
questions that we can discuss in the
comments so this is where we get our
little typing hats or mittens or
whatever you use to type you get that on
now because now we we leave comments
number one there's a rumor that Iron
Fist may not happen and we lose one of
the defenders check out our other
hashtag news update about that but do we
think that the fact that Jessica Jones
might be stealing the jeryn hogarth
character who's actually normally
related to the iron fist story means
we're more or less likely to see the
iron fist show actually happen number
two what is Luke Cage on the run from is
that why he ships over to Harlem instead
of staying with Jessica in Hell's
Kitchen you guys give me your best guess
go now this is the time the type number
three the Wil Simpson character in this
is a cop is he gonna become nuke and if
he does become nuke will he interact
with the purple man who we know already
is the main villain of the show
what's the hierarchy of villains in this
show okay so if you're still jonesing
for more Jessica okay all right philip
has been killing it lately with all of
his Jonesy insight so check out his
videos and make sure to subscribe if you
haven't already I will be following this
show and many others many other Marvel
Netflix Westeros nyan shows we know what
you like from now until forever we're
gonna be yeah and be sure to check out
our other New York Comic Con coverage
about other Marvel shows and movies that
may or may not be happening all right
all you Newsies I've been Gabe who
writer and I was not on vacation with
Drew I think I need to clear this stuff
I have no idea how that rumor started
drew and I have actually never even been
in the same place at the same time what
about this that's drew that who's Ted
you know I don't care I don't bye guys
I'm Ted
[Music]